the iPhone se is no longer a rumor it is
officially here it comes in three colors
a white a black and a product red and a
starting price at 399 it has touch ID so
it doesn't have face ID but it does
feature an a 13 Bionic chip which is the
same chip that is in the iPhone 11 Pro
its phone is going to be replacing the
iPhone 8 and it does a huge upgrade from
the original iPhone se that people loved
I'm obviously a huge fan of having a
larger screen size but for a lot of
people they don't need a larger screen
size they just need a phone that works
it makes calls they can take incredible
photos and videos and this could be the
phone for a lot of people especially if
they've been holding out on doing an
upgrade the storage capacity is 64 128
and 256 and it's crazy because the jump
from 64 to 128 is only a $50 upgrade
obviously 64 is not that huge of storage
but most of the stuff people need
nowadays you can store everything in the
cloud your photos your videos so if you
are looking to save obviously the 64
option is there but for a 128 upgrade
for 50 bucks you never know what you
might need that extra storage because I
never thought that I would fill up a 512
gig phone but guess who filled up their
phone me me the Apple logo is now
centered on the back it has haptic touch
it does only have one camera on the back
but with this you can still do portrait
mode it doesn't support pet portrait
mode but you can still do portrait mode
with people this one does not support
night mode unfortunately as it does only
have one lens you're not gonna have the
ultra wide or the telephoto this is just
the regular wide-angle the front camera
is 7 megapixels which also supports
portrait mode a lot of this is thanks to
the a 13 Bionic chip but because this is
giving this phone way more processing
power that's able to use algorithms to
enhance these photos so the back camera
is a 12 megapixel camera and this will
shoot 4k at 24 of 30 and 60 frames a
second and something that I forget about
quite a lot is the quick take video when
you press down the record button and you
swipe I don't let you quickly record a
video this also supports that it's
really great because this phone is so
powerful most of the features that
you're used to in iOS 13 will be running
just as smooth on this phone as it is
only
elevens the front camera only shoots
1084 does feature some cinematic video
stabilization so even if you are filming
with that front camera your footage will
be much more stabilized it is water and
dust resistance so it has a rating of
ip67 which means you can have it under
water up to 1 meter for up to 30 minutes
of course okay obviously something
that's not recommended but just to know
that if you do happen to drop your phone
into 1 meter of water it should be okay
as long as you get it out quickly it's
available for pre-orders on April 17th
and then availability on April 24th the
new S II is also Qi wireless compatible
which I wasn't actually quite surprised
at because the fact that this price is
so low that's usually something that
people cut first to try to keep the
costs down so I'm definitely glad that
this does have wireless charging it also
supports fast charge the charger that's
in the box though that it comes with is
not one of the fast charging bricks so
you will have to get a different one if
you do want to have fast charge it also
supports ECM and dual sims and is Wi-Fi
6 compatible but they can keep going
back through though is the price the
fact that this is still 399 which is the
same price as the iPhone se was in 2016
someone who wants to have the latest and
greatest in the newest of tech this is
not for you I think right now more than
ever people are using their phones
basically well I mean people use their
phones to communicate anyway but now in
this weird time that we're in the phone
is really our only kind of contact to
the outside world to our friends to our
family to our loved ones and there's a
lot of people that have older phones
that they're not even able to do
FaceTime or able to connect with people
in such an easy fashion definitely
looking forward to checking this out I
would love to hear from you guys what do
you think of the new iPhone se is this
something that you've been looking
forward to is this something you've been
holding out for do you think this is the
perfect phone for your parents for your
grandparents I would love to hear it all
in the comments below and if there's
anything else you would like to know
about this phone also leave those in the
comments and I can follow up when I
finally get one in my hands to unbox I'm
I just realized my switches right here
that's weird
hmm guess it's got time to check on my
island now hey Tom Nook are you gonna
get an iPhone se he definitely is
[Music]